remember Vimeo back in the late 2000s
and early 2010s if you searched for a
video on Google you would see a few
results from Vimeo and Daily Motion
personally I always thought of Vimeo as
just a YouTube copycat that wasn't
nearly as popular but it turns out that
Vimeo was and still is way more popular
than you might imagine in fact Vimeo has
a total of 230 million users from over
190 countries out of which 90 million
are active every month Vimeo also boasts
60 million content creators and a video
catalog that is growing by as much as
900 million videos per year but this
sizeable user base is pretty much the
only thing that Vimeo has going for them
as everything else has turned against
them basically just one look at their
stock will tell you everything you need
to know since going public in 2021 it's
been straight down for Vimeo who has
lost 93% of their market value which has
dipped down to $625 million at this
point they're almost trading at Book
value which isn't all that much lower
Vimeo has a total of $610 Million worth
of assets and $243 Million worth of
liabilities so their net asset stands at
$367 million if we subtract that from
the's current market valuation we'll see
that the business portion of Vimeo is
only worth $250 million for perspective
YouTube Pon that much revenue every 3
days seeing this I don't think you'd be
surprised to see that Vio has a
bankruptcy probability of 25% over the
next 24 months given this Bleak
situation Vimeo has been cutting
resources and staff but this has only
made the platform worse which has turned
the community against the company the
last thing they had going for them so
Vimeo is in this super precarious
situation where they still have nearly a
quarter billion users but all they have
to show for it is a company that's
slowly bleeding towards a bankruptcy and
an increasingly frustrated user base and
you know what the kicker about all of
this is Vimeo was never the YouTube
copycat they were actually the OG
YouTube having launched a couple of
months before YouTube so here's the
tragic fate of Vimeo the OG
YouTube taking a look back the story of
Vimeo traces back to late 2004 to Two
web developers named Jake lwig and Zack
Klein neither of these guys were some
sort of tech Wizards that dropped out of
Harvard or something they were just
modest software Engineers working at a
company that they thought was fun and
light-hearted College Humor this was
back when people actually used to watch
TV and this one SNL clip about this
singer Ashley Simpson was garnering a
lot of attention basically Ashley missed
her entry on live television which made
it painfully obvious that she was
lip-syncing she tried to play it off as
no big deal by dancing but this was
unfortunately the end of her singing
career the silver lining of the
situation is that this event is what
also gave rise to Vimeo you see the day
after this incident the video clip would
go viral on all sorts of platforms one
of which was called humor Jake and Zach
saw this explosion firsthand and decided
that it would be neat to create a
platform dedicated to tagging and
sharing short form videos just like this
so they whipped together a sight and
came up with the name Vimeo which was a
combination of the words video and me
the website would go live soon after in
November of 2004 but that was pretty
much it from there the website would
just organically grow through word of
mouth while Jake and Zach focused on
helping scale College Humor it wasn't
until nearly 2 years later that the duo
would really look back at the site you
see in August of 2006 Barry Diller the
founder of fox and USA broadcasting
would make an acquisition offer for the
parent company of college humor connect
adventures and during the due diligence
phase his team would come across Vimeo
they didn't think much of it and offered
to buy out everything for a total of $26
million
just a couple of weeks later though a
news bomb would drop from Google Google
was going to acquire YouTube for $
1.65 billion Diller immediately realized
that he had just accidentally stru gold
and would tell everyone at connect ADV
Ventures to go all in on Vimeo with Jake
and Zach at the lead by this point
YouTube had already become the sort of
mass Market video sharing platform so
instead of going after popularity Jake
and Zach decided to go after quality as
such they would focus their efforts on
better curating and offering a better
Creator and user experience one of these
efforts was bringing HD streaming to
online video in fact in October of 2007
viia would become the first online video
sharing platform to support HD streaming
out of the box but not always great at
Vimeo as Diller became more and more
concerned about making Vimeo successful
he would assert more and more influence
over the company for example he would
Implement a traditional corporate
structure like he had at his media
companies and bring in a bunch of his
trusted asso Associates but this simply
created a larger and larger Rift between
the original Vimeo team and the new
members eventually this tension would
blow over and Jake would decide to leave
but before he could he would actually
get fired in late 2007 just a couple of
months later Zach would also leave the
company and ever since then it's only
been downhill for the
company with the found out Vimeo would
decide to go all out on a complete
redesign of the platform they wanted the
video player to be the central focus of
any page unlike YouTube they would also
Implement a lot of restrictions around
what could and could not be uploaded to
Vimeo essentially they only wanted High
Roi content which was shorter videos
that could appeal to a broad audience
and this tunnel visioned goal led to
some pretty odd choices for example
starting in 2008 they would ban all
gaming content the reasoning was that
gaming content tended to be long and
take up a lot of resources while only
appealing to a niche group of returning
viewers they did eventually lift this
band in 2014 but this gave YouTube a
full six years to blow up in all sorts
of niches that Vio creators couldn't
even post about by this point there was
no catching up to YouTube so viia would
double down on trying to appeal to Indie
filmmakers and creatives for example in
2010 they would launch the Vio festival
and awards program this was basically a
competition for Rising film makers to
show off their work and gain exposure
around the same time they would
introduce 4K downloading support and in
2015 they would launch 4K streaming
support Lio also boasted far less
compression than YouTube in order to
better protect the Creator's original
Vision but while these efforts were able
to build a strong base of creatives
Vimeo was aiming for much more than just
that so in late 2016 they announced
their plans to spend tens of millions of
dollars on creating original in-house
content to compete against Netflix if
that sounds like a a crazy out there
idea it was and thankfully they didn't
go too far off the deep end before
coling quits just one year later but
this left Vimeo back at Ground Zero they
needed a new way to Pivot and continue
growing but with competing against
YouTube and Netflix directly being off
the table they really had no Direction
until they talked to a rising leader
named anel sud sud was a upen and
Harvard graduate that was currently
serving as the head of Global Marketing
for Vimeo and S had a completely
different vision for Vimeo instead of
being a consumer business what if they
became an Enterprise business there were
a lot of businesses that were left
behind by the age of the internet so
what if they help these businesses
create promotional videos and get
feedback before sharing it online with
not much to lose Vimeo board would
approve the pivot and place sod as the
new CEO of Vimeo in July of 2017 sod
would go on to Rebrand Vimeo as a SAS
platform and release a slew of editing
and review tools she would also complete
multiple Acquisitions that brought in
tens of millions of new users to Vimeo
for example in early 2019 she purchased
Magisto an AI video creation service
with over a 100 million users and in
late 2021 Vio would purchase yet another
AI based Bureau creation platform called
wibit while this was a rather unexpected
direction for Vimeo it seemed like
things were paying off Enterprise
customers quickly became VI's fastest
growing segment accounting for the vast
majority of the company's Revenue their
user count was also exploding thanks to
the pandemic reaching over 200 million
by late 2020 but the reality was that
Vimeo was a lot more fragile than any of
these numbers
[Music]
suggested one key point that we have yet
to discuss is how exactly Vimeo makes
money which turns out to be the
company's biggest shortfall naturally
you would think that Vimeo makes money
off of ads just like any other other
video sharing or social media platform
but Vimeo actually shows no ads at all
given that Vimeo targeted a higher-end
user base of filmmakers and creatives
they didn't want to bog down the
platform with a bunch of ads and as such
the only way that Vimeo makes money is
from creators and viewers directly
paying them creators and businesses have
to pay a fee based on how many videos
they upload and what features they want
and Vimeo also gets a 10% Commission on
any money that users are willing to
support creators with it's a pretty
straightforward model but it's not all
that profitable in fact despite having
over 200 million users Vimeo was only
pulling in a little more than $400
million per year or barely $2 per user
per year for perspective YouTube pulls
in closer to $11 per user per year and
Facebook pulls in over $20 per user per
year and given that video storage isn't
exactly cheap especially uncompressed
video storage Vimeo has never really
been profitable throughout most of sud's
leadership she just raised a bunch of
money to make up for this disparity for
example in 2020 she raised $150 million
and in 2021 she raised $300 million but
all of this peaked in mid 2021 when she
decided to take the company public at
a$1 billion valuation the harsh reality
was that investors simply didn't care
about investing in a second TI video
streaming platform especially one that
was losing money when they could just
invest in Google or Netflix and IPO day
itself Vimeo would fall 133% and it's
only been downhill since then as such
Vimeo has very much started focusing on
turning a profit which has led to some
pretty unpopular decisions on one side
they've been cutting resources which has
led to widespread buffering issues it
also seems that vim's UI is starting to
feel dated and their video creation has
very much fallen behind industry
standards something that they used to
lead but likely their most controversial
decision by far was jacking up prices
for content creators especially their
most popular and active creators in some
cases creators were expected to pay
thousands of dollars more just to keep
their content on Vimeo while extremely
unpopular though these drastic measures
have allowed the company to barely
become profitable they're currently
pulling in $8 million per year but at
what cost they're basically stuck in no
man's land with a bunch of angry users
and no real way to move forward s has
since been forced to step down and has
been replaced by a longtime Cloud
executive named Adam gross given that
Vimeo has been able to achieve
profitability I don't see them going
under with Adam but with that being said
it's also hard to see any sort of bright
feature ahead for Vimeo which is quite a
shame given that they were the OG video
streaming platform YouTube seems to be
facing their own crisis with ads and
short form hell check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm har and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]